[Music]
today's question comes from kyle in new
york he said my wife and i make around
165 000 a year combined i've been in my
job for about four years and i've never
gotten a raise or a promotion the
company has not given anyone a razor
promotion since i've been there that i'm
aware of it's a tech consulting company
but we work with very outdated
technology i've tried for over a year
now to get a new job but my skill set is
not aligned with all the newer
technologies required by the industry if
i don't get out now i'll be stuck in
this position forever but i need about
four to six months of studying and
upskilling at this moment having a
full-time job is making this impossible
i have about 40 000 in emergency funds
and i live in a very high cost of living
area should i quit my job and focus on
updating my skills and my resume
i don't think there's just an either or
option here that he's backed himself
into
i i personally would not quit you may
have a different opinion here dave but i
feel like both are possible even if it's
a part-time job in the tech consulting
world okay dude um
you need to let your boss know that
you're working 40 hours
not 80.
and then you need to throw a brick
through your tv
you have time to do the upskilling
i mean
just if you're working 40 hour week you
you can get your other skills
you can start doing code school at night
you can do code schools on the weekends
you write a check and get to get your
search
um but you don't ride this horse until
it dies it's dying
this horse is he's stumbling along he's
about to die you're in you're in a tech
field that is dying if they're not
upgrading not changing not moving
you don't have the option of working
there for the rest of your life because
this company's going to fail because
they're they're they're servicing only a
technology that is going away
apparently that's what it sounds like
and so you don't have a choice you have
to do this but you're you you've added a
little drama to this
uh so turn off your television
give up vacations
no whining
go back to school at night on weekends
get down to 40 hours and do that you can
do this you can do this i'm calling bs
on the i have to quit to go to school
yeah i don't believe it i mean
we got tech guys around here that are
always upscaling
and they're always doing all kinds of
stuff sometimes
sometimes they do it on the clock here
sometimes they've done it while they
worked at other places to get ready to
come to work here because we use cutting
bleeding edge stuff here
but um
oh man
yeah i mean it may be some long evenings
and long weekends if i don't get out now
i'll be stuck in this position forever
no you won't because they're gonna fail
you're not gonna be stuck you're gonna
be on the street
um
you know having a full-time job makes
this impossible now your your language
is just
traumatic yeah a lot of drama here
impossible
stuck forever
you know and now none of these things
are true so you're gonna be okay but
dude you are gonna have to sacrifice
like all your free time so going out to
eat with your little friends and stuff
no you're not gonna do that for a while
because you are you're getting
re-skilled and upskilled and moving
that's the people we meet on this
debt-free stage they find time to get
those side jobs and to find those side
hustles and it's worth it and to get
them to go to class and get the search
you know whatever it is you got to do
but it's it's there you can do this